prog riches c'est parti ah ah ah oui on
va partir sur la tête dans l'axé signe
un cas très dense on va démarrer alors
déjà on va quand même et on va faire
comme une méchante conseil en affaires
un premier tour au nord ou d'invités on
va jouer sur ton sont d'accord tu va
danser sur tons chauds et après je te
rejoins dray et les gens jugeront bien
entendu c'est parti
[Musique]
non
au volet
[Musique]
ça
tu sors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis né nous c'est à vous de voter
pour l'animal tapez 1 pour franck lui je
tapais 2,7 deschamps mais c'était sans
mes adversaires à moteur ça fait plaisir
on a joué sur tout terrain va je mets ma
main sur le bien voilà c'est parti
we sing
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on n'a pas le droit de faire le même pas
à chaque fois
alors c'est pas que je vais te dire
quelque chose c'est pas du tout de même
pas parce que si tu regardes bien tout à
l'heure je choisisse un deux trois alors
place à ces wayne été choisi exactement
même si tu es bien aimable en tout cas
je vois qu'il est fair play à toi bah si
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je prouverai
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
maintenant c'est ce qu'on appelle c'est
ce qu'on appelle dans le milieu de la
danse de la chanson la séquence
alors on doit garder nos distances de
sécurité non même si on est amis
c'est ce qu'on appelle maintenant le
adlib enfants 10 e adlib je connais ça
tu peux être un petit peu de la taf
vient du admis bitume veut dire à
volonté est vrai comme le bistrot
[Musique]
s'enchaîner oui dit n'importe quoi mais
il le dit avec aplomb 91 ans enchaîné et
c'est à vous de juger
j'avais ce soir les deux meilleurs
danseurs au niveau planétaire
c'est exceptionnel attention quatre
danses quatre danses pour un vainqueur
c'est parti on va danser ce qu'on
appelle simultanément à chacun son carré
à chacun son espace à chacun son univers
toi contre moi lions gate me rends
guiche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
l'araignée l'agglo
oh
[Musique]
j'ai aimé la désinvolture dans ce
m
ou pas
[Musique]
cela continue jusqu'à ma plage comme un
plâtre merci fera glisse franchement je
n'ai qu'une chose à dire rang des
français décideront oui je transpire
c'est rare c'est encore pire pour la
france merci je vous en avais pensé
qu'elle affronte philomena sincèrement
merci
il est exceptionnel il est sincèrement
je rassure sincère non sincère non je
trouve que cheryl était meilleure
franchement son corps il n'y a pas ce
n'est pas assez il est un peu étriqué
avec plaisir en faisant glisser tu es
une masterclass de sobriété c'était
parfait booster plus véronique et davina
c'était enfin véronique et davina
lörrach tendent à la salle de sports
c'est mon sens vous êtes imprégné de
tout ça histoire de la danse du
moyen-âge à nos jours
c'était très vulgaire très populaire pas
le cocker genest laval coupe i télé
thierry champion je t'ai pas vu dans ses
pas
[Applaudissements]
enfin je suis ravie enfin cyril qu'on
ait pu voir ce qui se passe dans votre
intérieur à l'extérieur vous avez su
montrer vos sentiments de justin dans ce
n'est pas une
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en même temps je sais que cette séquence
vous à émoustiller franglish avait deux
côtés professionnels de la danse vous on
est quand même ravi d'avoir vu votre
côté émotionnel et j'en suis très
contente mais non violent oui bonsoir
bonsoir si je puis me permettre je
trouve que vous avez un très beau
déhanché de gens mais je dis pas ça
parce que vous êtes mon patron d'accor
près bien voilà merci c'est vous qui
avaient demandé une augmentation aurait
mérité le doubs minimes france vichy les
minimalistes raffiné et vous vous êtes
l'animal pas dire des lags la
testostérone c'est en gros ce bruit
alors il m'a dit oui je renais bouaké
vraiment toi je sais que tu es dans la
danse se plieront pas oui à la tête je
suis connaît tous tout prix époustouflés
par 10 par qui a les deux c'est vrai
braquez peu plus à rien de jeter trouver
pohlad
ah oui lui c'est le jeune bernard authié
non moi je vous ai trouvé extrêmement
touchant parce que vous êtes donnés à
fond pour rien
j'ai enrichi est vraiment très stylé
ciel j'enlève montiel de mon répertoire
[Rires]
dont on a envie de prendre soin de vous
on a envie de nous on est entre 11 10
bat et on va lui apporter une bouteille
d'eau un défibrillateur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comme ce jeune leader
j'ai une vie beaucoup donné mais j'ai
beaucoup donné oui qu'est-ce qui m'a
regardé c'est bouleversant mais regarde
il fait ça aujourd'hui merci propre
livre
[Applaudissements]